I know we'll continue recording
as your boss does.
Alright, sounds good.
I thought this part was kind of awkward
because I kind of choked there.
This part felt pretty normal.
It was just like
I felt a little bit weird
above my neck fans.
I felt like I was rushing this part
a little bit
because I was kind of
really nervous.
I just wasn't really thinking about it.
Around here I stopped thinking about it.
I was just kind of
doing whatever.
But I kind of lost balance a little bit
because I was...
not very stable there.
This part was
alright.
I kind of
thought too much about the back one
so I lost more balance again.
And then this part was like
kind of when I clicked back in
and I was like, oh!
That was kind of scary.
Yeah.
Should I pause it here?
Okay.
Oh.